et je sens oh des élastiques qui
repartent dans l'autre sens et puis ça
commence à couler du nez de l'eau de
l'eau mais de l'eau de l'eau de l'eau de
l'eau
Johnny Hallyday l'exposition là ça sera
d'abord en Belgique puis en France alors
à l'expose plein de choses à cendrier un
slip et même elle pleuvra la descendre
est-ce que vous avez quelque chose mais
c'est un peu suffit d'avant mais on vous
l'achète pas c'est gratos on expose on
vous le rend après c'est pire
moi j'ai vraiment écouté monsieur et pas
depuis mon canapé et je peux te dire que
les objets qu'elle va qui vont être
exposées il y a par exemple des costumes
de scènes de Johnny des guitares etc ils
ont demandé à des collectionneurs des
objets en leur possession non qui ne
voulait pas venir pourquoi parce qu'ils
étaient obligés de payer le billet
d'entrée de l'expo et qui n'était même
pas payé donc qu'est-ce qu'elle doit
faire elle doit faire des répliques de
ses objets là donc ce ne sont même pas
les vrais dominants
si je te dis
et il y a des guitares qui vont être
mais ce seront pas les vrais constituer
le bureau quand tu vas au Louvre c'est
vraiment la Joconde
un petit peu parce que j'étais
interviewé à quelques années pour un
autre journal people et j'ai eu un peu
le même problème que Mathieu c'est à
dire que j'étais beaucoup parlé d'amour
j'ai essayé de savoir plein de trucs et
à la fin de l'interview je me suis dit
mais en fait elle m'a complètement
enrhumé j'ai rien compris j'ai rien
appris sur plein d'autres choses oui
mais sur l'amour
tu as rien voulu me dire donc ma
question elle rejoint un peu celle de
Mathieu c'est comment tu fais pour
rester aussi mystérieux et est-ce que
finalement si tu es amoureuse sinon t'as
pas envie de le partager avec avec le
plus grand nombre c'est vraiment un
choix personnel parce que j'ai envie de
me protéger moi j'ai aussi la personne
avec laquelle je suis qui n'a pas
forcément décidée
[Rires]
[Musique]
ça c'est très bien passé moi j'étais
mais j'étais très très surpris j'avais
toujours l'impression que la tête
flottée au-dessus de ma tête d'accord et
ça personne ah oui ou c'est quoi là oui
je me sens suspendue en fait d'accord en
2006 je fais avec une autre personne
donc médecin donc j'avais fait avec le
chirurgien
catastrophe trois jours après quand ça
commence à faire la fête je me rappelle
très bien j'étais assis devant la télé
et je sens pas deux explosions derrière
la tête je me suis dit là je fais un AVC
et puis je suis sorti glissement tout
doucement et n'alourdissement total de
tous mes visages tous les visages qui
s'est bloqué en bas
je suis quand même reconnu chez le
médecin qui m'avait fait le Botox un
mois après bagnole mais pourquoi vous
êtes pas venu plus tôt je sais que ce
qu'il faut faire donc il m'a injecté la
cortisone
commencez par des nœuds je voyais le
front avec des tri des des espèces de
est-ce contraction et oui effectivement
comme un Botox trois jours après je
m'allonge j'étais fatiguée parce que ça
c'est lourd hein
l'autre sens et puis et oui terrible
donc je sens et puis ça commence à
couler du nez de l'eau de l'eau mais de
l'eau de l'eau de l'eau de l'eau mais
j'étais mais j'avais plus de j'avais
plus rien c'était que du lot et je me
sentais vidé de lissage
on est obligé malheureusement de prendre
des chirurgiens qui font des opérations
à des coûts très réduits ou à
l'épongeurs et qui du coup
moins bien
parce que est-ce que les médecins
marocains tunisiens et tout sont moins
moins qualifiés que les médecins
français ça c'est très intéressant alors
quand c'est pas cher il y a un piège
esthétique la chirurgie esthétique low
cost depuis danger on a une chance en
France c'est qu'on a le pays qui a la
meilleure sécurité en matière de
chirurgie esthétique au monde numéro 1
au monde en matière de sécurité donc
c'est pas logique d'aller se faire
opérer à l'étranger je comprends que
pour économiser quelques centaines
d'euros quelques milliers d'euros que
parfois il y ait des patients des
patients le problème c'est que ces
patients et patiente reviennent en
France certains sont satisfaits
satisfaites d'autres pas du tout se
rendre compte que c'est pas du tout ce
qui voulait que les cicatrices sont
moches que les seins sont de travers que
il faut tout reprendre donc vous avez
beaucoup vous justement dans la médecine
réparatrice de la chirurgie enfin oui
j'en ai beaucoup justement
que j'en ai et parfois je dis bah
écoutez non je suis pas capable de
réparer ça ou je ne veux pas me lancer
dedans et quand je me lance dedans
malheureusement ma grand-mère disait
acheté mon marché s'est acheté deux fois
là en chirurgie esthétique acheter bon
marché payer bon marché c'est payer
trois fois parce que si vous payez une
somme X en Tunisie au Maroc en Turquie
ou peu importe et que vous revenez et
que le résultat n'est pas du tout à la
hauteur de vos espaces bien sûr vous
payez le double
84% des Français dans le milieu des
stars sont pistonnés alors j'ai d'autres
chiffres la politique c'est 35% la
littérature 11% notamment envie d'être
avec la musique 10% et pour 70% des
Français le piston reste aujourd'hui la
plus grande forme d'injustice je dis que
c'est normal de pistonner son enfant
s'il a du talent par exemple
si je peux l'aider je pense que toutes
les mamans dans le public elles peuvent
aider leurs enfants avoir un job elle le
feront et tous les papas aussi
c'est un génie non si l'enfant est nul
c'est préjudice c'est ce qu'elle dit
d'ailleurs c'est ce qu'elle dit
Alexandra Lamy elle dit si elle avait
été nulle la pauvre la mette à l'écran
c'est pas lui rendre service quand on a
vu par exemple Lou Doillon
quand elle a fait actrice elle était nul
à chier après elle a trouvé sa voix elle
est devenue chanteuse et elle était
exceptionnelle il y a des enfants qui
vont toujours ramer qui sont toujours
être pas bien que leurs parents la fille
de Romy Schneider elle a jamais réussi à
percer je suis désolé je trouve pas
qu'elle est un talent de dingue et puis
sa mère était une icône absolue parce
que déjà c'est des jeunes qui ont vécu
dans un univers artistique donc ils sont
déjà prédestinés à être à faire un
métier un peu comme leurs parents parce
que voilà quand on travaille quand on
est fils de pilote de Formule 1 on est
tenté on fait du kart etc on est dans ce
métier là et puis c'est les pistons ça
marche dans tous les métiers quelqu'un
il travaille la poste ils pissonne son
fils pour qu'il travaille aussi l'été à
la poste etc ça arrive juste dans tous
les métiers donc oui ils sont pistonnés
mais pas plus que les autres les autres
Français voilà